les mensonges autour du masque les
hésitations autour du masque seront
peut-être ce qui restera hélas de cette
épidémie
cette pandémie depuis cédé 4 avons
affronté le présent la république
récemment disait que fin février et
début mars
personne ne parle et des masques c'est
faux des collectivités des mairies des
régions s'équiper de masse l'anticiper
la nécessité pour se protéger et pour
protéger les autres en cas d'épidémie de
mettre un masque fallait pas être devin
divisé de lire si c'était fait ailleurs
et les études nous l'avons fait à quatre
avec d'abord de grosses commandes de
masques ffp2 les chirurgies cours on en
avait déjà un stock on a équipé tous nos
agents les policiers municipaux alors
qu'une nation ne rêvez pas quel symbole
de la déliquescence de l'état régalien
on a fourni à l'hôpital alors c'était au
ministre de la santé de le faire on a
fourni au tribunal et qui ont lancé
cette fabrique de masques alternatif qui
vous a permis bordant le confinement
d'équiper les habitants de masques
protecteurs aux normes afnor les plus
protectrices
mais derrière tout cela cette crise elle
révèle un dysfonctionnement majeur de
l'organisation de pouvoirs publics en
france
ce n'est pas une un défi phénomène dû à
un phénomène unique qui est la pandémie
du colis 19 c'est la traduction d'un
dysfonctionnement majeur entre
l'organisation des pouvoirs et du
caractère totalement obsolète
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics avec
un état qui se veut omnipuissant et qui
en fait de lire un peu de temps parce
qu'il veut tous occupés tout au couvrir
et qui est défaillant sur le régalien la
police la justice parfois l'armée
souvent la diplomatie bref c'est
pourquoi il n'était fait pour protéger
la communauté et les communes les
collectivités ont su protéger mieux que
l'état donc cela doit nous interroger
sur l'avenir
comment faire en sorte que l'état soit
fort il donne quelques rues et qu'il
efface triplement respecté qu'il assure
l'équité la solidarité mais qu'ils
laissent les initiatives se développer
qu'ils cessent d'étouffer les libertés
c'est cela que nous devons porter c'est
pour ça que je suis républicain parce
que je crois à l'ordre et à la liberté
je ne crois pas au schéma des années 50
et d'après guerre il y a autre chose à
inventer pour que la société reprenne
toute sa place que l'état soit sa juste
place celle de la garantie des libertés
et celle de la protection notamment des
plus démunis aujourd'hui c'est nous
allez l'air très souvent dans nos
régions dans nos communes dans le
département qui avons assumé la
protection et qui avons fait gagner la
communauté il faudra leur emprunt
national
[Musique]